michel serrault est-ce que je peux
enlever sa la pa semi en mairie un
minimum mais un peu de respect pour le
néant mais le reste est oui pour le prix
de la relève le nom il est allé lui
servait c'est l'ange blanc qui va le
faire l'ange blanc s'il vous plaît
autant
dimanche deux ans qu est ce qu un beau
mélange non alors donc ce bouquin wii
commence par l'énoncé de votre
philosophie à l'épaule ou juillet knock
au théâtre et puis y avait des gens qui
veulent voir dans la loge comme ils vont
voir laurent d'ailleurs tous les soirs
pour le féliciter
il ya une dame qui vient et qui vous dit
excusez moi de vous dire ça monsieur ce
héros et vous
il ya une dame qui vient qui vous dit
d'antibes égayaient c'est lui qui vous
admirent sa chute elle a dit quoi cette
dame alors alors il ya une dame qui
vient vous voir donc et qui vous dit
excusez moi monsieur zéro mais vous
m'avez tellement fait rire et vous lui
répondez que vous excusez pas madame je
les fais exprès et toute la philosophie
de michel serrault et contenus dans
cette réplique d'une certaine façon
alors dans ce genre de réflexion ce que
j'ai lu dans votre bouquin c'est que à
l'époque où vous jouiez la cage aux
folles il ya une dame qui a dit quand
même pour ce rôle il aurait quand même
pu trouver une femme non oui mais voilà
comme ça ces prophètes un formidable on
allait boire un verre à la fin du
spectacle juste en face du palais royal
et il y avait là il y avait deux couples
et les gens étaient ravis de la soirée
alors ils étaient là moi j'étais
démaquiller et puis de griffures yeux
j'étais bon
elle me reconnaissent pas et j'entendais
les commentaires sur le spectacle est en
forme il a bien eu lieu
or met alors sur des bâtons monsieur
poiret pilotera belle-soeur et di meco
de germaine ya une chose que je
comprends pas mais il y avait bien
apparaît une comédienne pour jouer le
rôle de monsieur c alors au début du
livre vous parlez de notre enfance on a
déjà raconté ici moi j'ai appris c'est
tellement loin maintenant monde où et
quand je dis alors après vous parlez de
votre maître dans l'art dramatique jean
le goff jean le conflit qui fuse a
appris le boulot quoi ils disaient ou
aux acteurs aux jeunes acteurs écoute
c'est une écoute pas tu ne peux pas
répondre ça va de soi les coûts de ton
partenaire regarde le soit vraiment avec
lui est une chose essentielle quand on
joue la comédie et respire ouais mais
respirent la respiration de l'auteur
c'est à dire que le si vous ne trouvez
pas la cadence et la respiration de dans
molière dans l'art pago dans tous les
maliens et bien qu'est-ce qui se passe
et bien l'acteur va disparaître
asphyxiés il va s'étouffer des décors
sont de rejet 1 et 2 centimes dont
donald cardwell
cette fois très jaune tout c'est en tous
les cas michel c'est toujours une photo
dédicacée de jean le goff en masse de
vous chez vous où est écrit à michel
serrault qui sera un grand pitre et ce
qui pourrait être pris comme quelque
chose de péjoratif pour vous c'est
toujours été un grand compliment ce qui
compte les mots comptent dans la quand
on joue la comédie le texte compte
énormément
mais c'est les intentions si tu dis à
quelqu'un lui c'est un pitre poserait
bien vrai mais lui il a un teint grand
pitre ouais alors là ça devient
magnifique
tout est dans l'intention alors vous
raconter dans ce livre enfin votre
rencontre avec jean poiret c'était
devant le théâtre sarah bernhardt vous
il a que tous les deux pour
roll et puis lui vous dis comme ça vous
connaissiez pas lui vous dit de toute
façon je suis sûr d'être engagé j'ai une
fortune personnelle et vous ne visitez
comme moi ma mère connaît la cousine du
concierge et on a beau dire le piston
sajoo oui c'est sûr mais là vous êtes
trouvé sur ces deux répliques pleines de
non sens et les rencontres c'est le
hasard et la nécessité
on avait beaucoup de mal à jouer la
comédie on a des 22 ans quelque chose
très rare et c'était pas les jeunes
premiers il avait toujours les jeunes
premiers au théâtre avec 40 ou 45 ans ça
a changé un peu mais on avait des
difficultés la seule façon de gagner ça
glisse était d'aller ou cabaret
ouais alors vous vous rencontrez donc
devant le théâtre sarah bernhardt ces
deux répliques évidemment vous vous
réunissez et une amie c'est qu'il y aura
40 ans
et un jour un jour jean poiret vous dis
tu veux pas qu'on essaye de monter un
truc tous les deux et là votre première
source d'inspiration a été la télévision
et pourtant à l'époque la télévision
pas beaucoup de postes à faire c'était
53 et déjà la vacuité des interviews
télévisées
c'est assez grave à l'époque apparemment
et vous créer un personnage qui
s'appelle jerry scott vedettes
internationales
c'était qui c'était un acteur français
parce que pour les gens n'est ce pas un
acteur français mais disons que c'est ce
qu'on entendait un peu partout dans les
commentaires pour être un grand acteur
il fallait passer de toute façon par la
mairie il y avait pas d'acteurs français
à la hauteur des américains donc nous on
avait fait un personnage qui était
france a été comme à mener en ouvert
nous quelque part cette année c'est
toute sa carrière en amérique et revenez
un jour dire bonjour à la france et
c'était un ringard
ouais en fait vos débuts au tabou dans
un club de jazz rue dauphine 11 janvier
53 à l'annonce de poids est incroyable
une énorme vedette internationale et
cetera
et là vous arrivez vous dans votre
costume gris un peu comme un comme
guichetier de banque sans sourire et ils
vous interviews et on découvre vous
étaient cinq films à hollywood riches
vieux richelieu à richelieu et des tu
viens de tourner toute une série y'avait
richelieu chez les nazis style et
frankenstein
alors là c'est incroyable donc en une
nuit venez star tous les deux un papier
de max favalelli et commence le marathon
des cabarets c'est à dire vous faites la
tomate à 22 heures chez gilles à 00h30
le tabou à 2 heures le sketch comme ça
vous juillet dans la nuit ces gens
devant moi terrain en phase pré fall
enfin pourrit pas passé le même sketch à
l'arrêt avec 4 ris avec quatre choses il
fait ça il y avait donc clément laprade
explorateurs donc on la marie vielles
vous dit j'ai du retard des trois fois
mon départ alors ils disaient pourquoi
vous avez des difficultés pour unir le
matériel et vous répondiez non pleyel
était pas libre section frais y avait un
sketch aussi c'était stéphane bras vil
prix littéraire oui ça tout le monde y
passe et c'était au départ c'est
toujours des interviews rien qu'est ce
que vous écriviez à cette époque là je
palais et à la cour tout bas
il y avait un moment aussi où il disait
en pleine occupation vous avez quand
même soutenu que shakespeare était
allemand oui alors vous répondiez enfin
jusqu'à fin 44
on est revenu à un flux et le fameuse
caisse des antiquaires donc un couple
d'homosexuels 15 ans avant la cage aux
folles dans dans cette parodie d'une
interview comme ça oui parce que nos
femmes et aimait beaucoup les
antiquaires est vrai et c'est beaucoup
d'endroits et on connaît on avait des
amis qui tient des boutiques
extraordinaire et on a fait avec jean on
a fait un truc folie ouais ils voulaient
me vendre
j'ai vu une dame qui rentrait dans la
boutique et finalement elle va le
trouver pour ce qu'elle voulait épuiser
mais je vous le vent lui n'y sert à quoi
il sert à rien et qu'elle pose et lorsqu
incroyable michel serrault si vous avez
fait donc les antiquaires 15 ans avant
la cage aux folles et pareil pour vos
rôles sérieux c'est à dire qu'à l'âge de
26 ans vous tournez les diaboliques de
clouzot film vous êtes un personnage
assez sérieux il a fallu attendre des
années après avant vous fassiez l'argent
des autres gardes à vue ou le docteur
petiot
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire ça veut
dire que les gens n'ont pas à me dire
allez j'en ai souvent les acteurs pierre
quand on avait aussi eu un parcours un
peu bizarroïdes
bon j'ai voulu être clown j'ai voulu on
a fait du music hall on a écrit des
sketches on a joué au théâtre g terrain
on n'était pas des gens très sérieux
quoi vrai on n'était pas des vrais
acteurs et puis un jour c'était à la
tomate c'est que nous on qu'il ne me
voir et me dit voilà mon cher ami je
connais un peu avec les gens et ce
terrain si vous vous y ait tourné dans
mon
ouais si vous voulez bien de moi puis
voilà
et puis voilà un soir de novembre 67
effectivement gens et vous allez voir
l'escalier donc avec paul meurisse et
daniel ivernel à la comédie des champs
elysées donc c'est l'histoire la pièce
l'escalier c'est l'histoire de deux
vieux homos qui s'envoient des vacheries
à la gueule toute la soirée et il vous
dit pourquoi on fait pas une pièce mais
comique dans le style des antiquaires